こんにちははじめ社長です
[音楽]
あの
先日
動画を出させていただいた
はじめした超の
ユーチューバーあるあるソング
だっけまずし一番忘れちゃいけないとか忘れてしまった
あっあってますから10中盤ある阿部ソングという動画を出させていただいたんです
けどもあの映像来の仲だとちょっとわかりにくかったんですが私サブチャンネルの方に
年キング道路出させて歌えているんですけどもあるシーンの中に
明らかに
僕ではない人の手が
映り込んでいたんですよ
ブーブーシーンか明日とプーユーチューバーのあー基礎ださーいって ur を言っ
てるシーンこちら
[音楽]
ブーバーし
この押入れから出てくる押入れの中あの中にいる時に撮ったメイキングの中のマン
シーンの僕のってなん
お礼んじゃないんですよね玉名てマーカーなどが光の加減では色々あるんでしょうけど
ちょっとご覧くださいこちらです
どうぞ
i am
[音楽]
[拍手]
うん
どうでしょうか twitter とかで困ってるやばくないっていうのあってきたん
ですけど
確かに自分で見てもすごいなってなって
いやーこれまずで映っちゃいけないやつなんだろうなっていう気がしてすごく怖かった
んですよ
何度もその c 見返したんですけどもあんなにわかりやすく
人の手っていうか教えの奥から生えているような
ての生え方してるうのが見て
怖かったです
今回話ししたいのはそういう話じゃないまあこれをしたかったんですけどこれをし
たかったですようわなんかノーシール10篇があるんだっていう話で今なかったら
申し訳ないんですけどちょっとすごいそういう強い雰囲気があったという話と
もう怖い話終わりなんだんしてくださいなんと9月の23日
今日からユーチューバーあるあれソングの楽曲がいろんなアプリとかで
配信されません
[音楽]
されませんしませんユーチューバーあるそむ
a 間に配信されることはありませんはーい
なんだなんじゃたんでー
あああああ街があるんですよあのちゃんと理由があるんでそれよあの聞いてください
ユーチューバーンっていう言葉
何がダメなんですってっ
何か食べたんですってまあいろんな都合がなんか色んな大人の事情がんですよあのもう
本当に俺だけじゃないよ
みんなよユーチューバーという言葉でなんかこうなんかいろいろあるんですよこんな
google さんのなんかとか商標登録の話とか youtube はいいけど輸注
バーはダメとかなユーチューバーて別の意味が実はあったとかいろんな
没はこちらがゴリゴリに
あった結果ユーチューバーという言葉で楽曲配信にするのはダメたんですねじゃあ何で
この曲作ったかって
ユーチューバーの歌だからなんですよなんで俺はもうその音楽作りを曲だよってなった
時は絶対ユーチューバーということ入れたかったユーチューバーということは入れない
とをもう動画になんない
音楽にならない曲にならないと思ってユーチューバーある
あれソング汁を作ったんですけどもあくまで俺のこのチャンネルだけでしか言えません
学級編成従って俺もユーチューバーある削ぐって曲だしたかったあの apple
ミュージックとか
スポーティフ8か line music ときましたまーやーねーよああ
パーッと呼びでは載せませんユーチューバーあるソングは a といっしょ楽曲配信さ
れることはないんですけど
その代わりにその代わりですね5話の配信をちょっとされているんですけども曲の名前
が
動画作る人をあるあるソングでございます
ぷっ
うーそういうしかないじゃんユーチューバーってことながらなんかお店ずつダメで曲の
だけど結構ユーチューバーということを使ってたりするんですけども曲のタイトルも
ダメで作詞中にもユーチューバーという言葉でちゃった人がいろいろあってちょっと
変わってますちょっとか私タイトルもユーチューバーあるソングではなく楽曲配信され
ているのは動画作る人ハーフ圧ソングっていう名前で
影響から配信されておりま
まーすまあどう変わってるかとかかし変わってたりするんでそうだどう変わってる
かっていうのもあるの楽しみの一つなんですけどもユーチューバーという言葉を使って
楽曲味は無理だったんで
動画作る人っていう言葉になったりクリエータという言葉を使ったりいろいろこうなん
とか試行錯誤して出したんですけど今日から配信されておりますのでぜひ良かったら
みなをダウンロードしてください
動画概要欄からなんか色んながある
んでそっから皆さんが使ってる音楽アプリでぜひ聴いてみてください
驚きでしょユーチューバーっていう言葉ってなんか実はよくないらしい
俺は折脚はおれはおれはおれオレは知らんけど俺は知らんけどでお菓子だけどなんか
ちょっとねあの使い勝手が難しい言葉らしくて詳しいことはすいませんの僕の口からは
ちょっと今泉友なぁいい主は勝ってもないかもしれませんけど
色あんな音味は勝手だし
なかったということだけを今日この動画で示しておきますめっちゃ怪しい
生まれると思うんですよなんでユーチューバールソンがじゃないのって言われると思う
んですけどもそういうことなんですよ
ハチャメチャな状況になってるんですけどもまぁそういうことをぜひご理解いただける
と嬉しいでございますぜひユーチューバーるさんぐと動画作る人アナルソングあの
聴き比べてみてください
じゃーんっ
ます
あっはーるへ行っは